okay okay we're here we're here right  now it's go time  should i be concerned about my security  this hasn't actually ever been filmed  before  [Applause]  money is the root of all evil  we're heading to meet the owner of a  drug operation  do you have a phone i do i want to have  it what's happening  [Music]  we're thinking of taking our cameras of  course  i don't know how to feel about this  what are you gonna do with 19.42 million  dollars they were billionaires before  bill gates this is the infamous human  experiment  it's military grade listen being  superhuman is the game  it's a massive massive fraud town was  built on coke money  sounds like money to me now  no one knows what's going on behind  closed doors  you